but hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the
conservative commentator tim montgomery
and the director of the john smith
center at the university of glasgow
kezia dugdale and they'll be with us
right through until midnight so to the
front pages then let's start with the
telegraph in the wake of today's a-level
results the telegraph reporting that
ministers are considering scrapping
letter grades and replacing them with
numbers in an effort to more accurately
reflect pupils performances
the guardian points out the disparity
between the higher grades given to
private school students and the low
marks given to their state school
counterparts
the metro reacts to the civil lawsuit
brought against prince andrew in the u.s
alleging sexual abuse their headline
enough to make a duke sweat we should
point out he strongly denies the claims
the financial times leading with the u.s
senate's passage of a landmark
infrastructure bill that will see a
trillion dollars pumped into its ailing
transport system
the sun hears that dancer nadia bishkova
who's due to appear on the upcoming
series of strictly has tested positive
for covid and the star says the spices
used in south asian food can have an
aphrodisiac effect
as it does anyway tim montgomery kezia
doug taylor here and welcome to both of
you lots of news about exam results uh
whether it be the hires in scotland or
the a levels um and kesia the guardian
pointing out that the the gap between
private and state school pupils has
grown again um amidst a backdrop of
course of of escalating grades great
inflation we used to call it but now we
say well done to the students
yes and we should say well done because
they've come through one of the worst
years imaginable in terms of their
education the kind of wider effects on
society and the newspapers and news
buildings are full of pictures of young
people celebrating but there's a darker
more worrying story behind the scenes
and that's that the gap between those
peoples from state schools and those
from private schools is as the guardian
describes as large as it's been in the
modern era so what we know is that kovid
exacerbates pre-existing
inequalities and that applies to the
school system as much as it does
anything else
and tim it's not just the difference is
it between state school pupils who got
nearly 45 percent of a or a star while
independent sector got around 70 of a or
a star um there seems to be a gender gap
issue as well that the guardian
highlights a subject gap that some
subjects did better under this teacher
assessment than others and a regional
disparity too suggestions that the north
east of england for example which we
know was badly hit with covid as one
minister said today has levels of
deprivation also saw poorer figures so
what kobit has done is thrown up all
these difficulties haven't they where
does this leave us now as we as we go
forward then
well i think it leaves our exam system
and in a complete mess clearly the
grades that have been awarded
to uh students aren't comparable with
anything we've seen before and if
normally we were seeing a widening gap
between private and state schools
between uh different between boys and
girls between different regions we'd
want to look at perhaps some of the
structural reasons uh why that was
happening just for the this year and the
last year we can't really trust the
grades unfortunately and as soon as
possible we need to get back to some
sort of normality where teachers in
particular aren't marking their own
pupils exam results now i completely
agree with what kezia's just said and
the the kids involved the students
involved they've had a terrible couple
of years and we absolutely as a society
owe them all the support and comfort we
can but the exam system
if it carries on like this will
completely lose the confidence of
employers and universities and we have
to get back to a system where exams are
independently marked and certified as
soon as possible
and that's the point
made in the financial times isn't it
kezia um ufc uh john smith center
university of glasgow um top grades for
45 of a level entries sets tough
questions for universities uh now as
certainly pointed out um for england
that when a's became
too high
uh nearly 25 percent that's when the a
star was brought in around a decade ago
you've got a bigger issue now that
universities simply can't distinguish
the the very good students from the
truly best students so what do
universities do what and does it matter
for these two years is it is this just a
blip and and not to take it too
seriously
well there is an element of taking big
public policy decisions off the back of
a pandemic that might be ill-advised i
think there's a much more fundamental
question here though which is about the
role of exams in the school system and
indeed the wider education system that
we should be asking ourselves lots of
universities across the country are
reviewing whether they're going to have
what we call high stake assessments at
all anymore this idea that an exam at
one point in a calendar year and decides
your future fate is perhaps now outdated
and we should have a lot more continuous
assessment lots more types of
assessments which are more like real
life like presentation skills are
writing brief papers rather than five
thousand word dissertations there's lots
and ways in which the education system
can evolve and i teach at the university
of glasgow and all of these questions
are being asked in our own institution
if we change at the university of
glasgow and all the russell group
institutions change their ways then
there's even more pressure in the school
system to ask itself if exams is the
right way forward yeah we had that
didn't we we had continuous assessments
the problem is you know there's a gender
bias to that it seemed to favor girls
tim
uh teach to exams is the other criticism
obviously um daily telegraph uh
suggesting that a level a levels
themselves need to be be thrown out now
perhaps bring in a numbered base system
like gcses which have one to nine maybe
nine to three i heard one suggestion
today is it time to look again do you
think or is it time to to really think
do exams deliver what they need to do
i certainly think it's um one thing that
the uh government needs to look at the
whole education system needs to to look
at and obviously it's the thing we're
focused on today because we've had um a
level of results if i was education
secretary or prime minister i'm not sure
it would be my priority just at the
moment i think the fundamental priority
for the education system is to
particularly look at the catch-up
challenge facing particularly
disadvantaged pupils and if you're a kid
lucky enough to have a supportive home
uh where um
you know your parents are perhaps you
know reasonably well educated themselves
you've suffered during this covey period
but probably you've been relatively well
supported if you're in a home perhaps a
home where you share a bedroom with a
younger sibling or something where your
parents haven't themselves
attained in traditional educational way
you haven't been that well supported
that's where i think the education
secretary should be focusing his efforts
um and unfortunately as we've seen today
the education secretary gave miserable
performances on most of the morning
interviews he undertook and he didn't
really answer any of the questions i
heard him posed by nick robinson on the
bbc radio 4 today program today i'm a
conservative supporter anna but i think
he's about the worst cabinet minister
we've had since the conservatives came
to power in 2010 we need someone new in
charge of the education system he's
simply not up to the job and we really
need boris johnson to get on with a much
needed reshuffle well i was going to ask
you about that just very quickly then
will there be one what's your reckoning
i think there should have been one
already mrs thatcher when she had her
reshuffles always did them at the start
of the summer and that allowed ministers
as they were on holiday away from
parliament to begin to read into their
briefs i don't quite understand it but
the prime minister's hesitancy on a
reshuffle just means that he's not
getting the right caliber of ministers
in place in a timely way
well the telegraph pointing out that
gavin williamson suggested that any
switch to a numerical grading system
would take a little bit longer to be
implemented and would not be ready for
next year's exams uh the paper suggests
his comments suggest that grade
inflation will continue for a number of
years until any new system is ready to
be implemented we'll have to wait and
see obviously um kezia should we go to
the metro now
this is after the news broke in new york
last night
their headline as they show prince
andrew looks like arriving in balmoral
for a scottish summer break
enough to make a duke sweat referencing
obviously that interview he did with
news night some time ago
but it doesn't go away does it for the
royal family
no this is a deeply uncomfortable story
for the wider royal family as much as it
is for prince andrew himself who's of
course denying all of the allegations
put towards him however and he's already
taken a couple of steps back from public
life it's hard to see how much further
he can retreat without facing out to
some of these questions very difficult
few days ahead for prince andrew because
i think the story will only grow arms
and legs and it's also worth pointing
out that should this issue end up in the
civil courts in america it might just
happen at the same time as the royal
family would rather we were all talking
about the platinum jubilee next summer
so the timing's unfortunate these are
very serious allegations and it's hard
to see
how chris sandra will have any other
choice than then to make some more
public comments about them and he's
taken on a very um important role for
the queen hasn't he um you know often
being there by her side spending time
with her uh will people have sympathy
with her do you think during this tim
what will what will the reaction be to
this
well i think that i think the public
loves the queen the queen has popularity
ratings that politicians would dream
of having and prince andrew does not
have those um popularity uh ratings and
um we none of us know what the uh the
truth of these latest allegations are
but we we do know anna from that news
night interview you mentioned the alibis
that he put forward such as going to the
woking pizza express didn't add up uh we
saw him sort of wriggle about the fact
that he um revisited
um
the sex offender you know the heart of
these allegations now dead of course
when he really shouldn't have touched
him with a a barge pole and we know that
you know some of his he just didn't show
any remorse for even having any
connection with that whole setup and his
reputation has been so damaged by that
interview
and that the public will have little
sympathy for him i fear but you know
people are innocent until proven guilty
but um i think in terms of his general
judgment he's already been tried in the
court of public opinion and been found
guilty yes this of course is a civil
case in the new york courts uh kezia
most of those are settled uh it has big
implications of whether or not he's
required to give evidence uh but
listening to a new york professor
speaking to my colleague a little
earlier
about this the suggestion is that
evidence heard in a civil case could
then lead to a criminal case which is
what happened to helene maxwell so
definitely tense times and keeping his
lawyers close no doubt
yes absolutely and there's also a huge
difference between civil and criminal
proceedings around whether or not
prince andrew could be in some
circumstance forced to give evidence if
it remains a civil case it's quite
likely that he wouldn't have to hear the
charges in fact it's pretty difficult as
we've heard from experts today for even
a writ to be served across the
antiquation so and he's he's not going
to be able to wriggle out of the process
completely it's just a lot more
difficult but as you say should civil
leads to criminal that's a completely
different ball game and suddenly things
like extradition rules can kick in and
he could be forced to face charges if it
were to end in that situation and of
course we have to say that these are
very serious allegations but they are
allegations and the guardian
the ft showing a little boy um cowering
the suggestions that afghans are fleeing
the the taliban tide and certainly we
know that the defense secretary here in
the uk is watching nervously um one
wonders what joe biden thinks of this
having pulled out
the americans but i mean this is
this is just not good is it tim
this story and it makes my blood boiled
to be honest and that picture on the
front of the ft that poor little child
you know with rubbish around him and the
possessions of his family probably
fleeing from from persecution you know
the western world made a promise to
afghanistan
that we wouldn't run away
from you know the intervention that we
made and we have done that president
biden when he was in cornwall for the g7
summit said america is back well i'm
afraid america is back home we've
abandoned people like that little boy i
think we've abandoned the memory of a
lot of people including british soldiers
who died in afghanistan i think the
sacrifices that we made have allowed a
huge number of women to be educated in
that country we freed a people um nearly
40 million people from one of the most
murderous odious
regimes the taliban regime and to have
given up now withdrawn in such a
precipitate way it is shameful and i'm
afraid in a world where we're in a
strategic competition with the likes of
russia and china to have abandoned our
responsibilities and to bring into
question the trustworthiness of the west
i think it's shameful really shameful
well the ft says uh quoting an eu
official said the militants now
controlled 65 of the country a u.n
official added that advances in human
rights in the 20 years since the
islamists were ousted risked being
erased and the front of the guardian
has an article by a young female
journalist who says two days ago i had
to flee my home and life in the north of
afghanistan after the taliban took my
city i am still on the run and there is
no safe place for me to go
last week i was a news journalist today
i can't write under my own name or say
where i am from or where i am my whole
life has been obliterated in just a few
days i am so scared and i don't know
what will happen to me that is a young
woman who was a journalist and
presumably will not be able to be one
after this kezia
yes it's utterly haunting and
devastating and i wouldn't say a word
out of kilter with what tim has just
described i think he's absolutely right
and i actually don't think all the us
troops have left afghanistan yet it was
a promise that they would all be gone by
an arbitrary date by set by president
biden in september so i think it's quite
possible there are still troops there
although they're on their way out and
yet we're in the situation whereby at 65
percent of the territory has already
been taken back by the taliban and we
see the practical realities of what that
means in these stories it's that little
five-year-old boy in a rubbish he puts
women who had rights you know a matter
of years ago feeling they like they've
got no future whatsoever so it's utterly
devastating
and we should feel collectively very
guilty about this
throughout history afghanistan has
suffered at the hands of
other countries so many promises made so
many promises broken and each and every
time we somehow seem surprised what
we've left behind i just i couldn't
agree more with what tim has said
tonight
to the telegraph now tim alex sharma
president of the cop 26 u.n climate
change conference
still drives a diesel car it feels like
one of those questions when politicians
used to be asked um how much is a as a
pint of milk it's kind of that basic
isn't it
it is really and um he's had a bad week
alex sharma because i think it was about
this time last week we were learning
that he'd been jetting around the world
avoiding uh quarantine rules that
applied to the rest of us and i had a
little bit of more sympathy with him
last week because actually we do know
that zoom meetings work okay but
actually if you really want to you know
get stuff done with people face-to-face
meetings work
but um i think if you're trying to
convince the rest of the world and the
public that you're serious about the
environment i think i would have traded
in my diesel car by now and already got
an electric car yes uh he says it will
almost certainly be an electric car next
time that's not that's not 100 convinced
he might either miss it
tim montgomery casey dougdale super to
have you both on thank you